[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين
الولايات المتحده
عام 88 و 9000 قصدي محاكمته
مجلس النواب بتحريك دعوه جنائيه ضد كل من
تورط في تسليمه لجهات اجنبيه
السلطه القضائيه والمحكمه الدستوريه في
هيئه صياغه الدستور سيد همم المنصوري اهلا
بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه هذه
الدعم
مرحبا بك وضيوفك الكرام شكرا دكتور
المقابل من واشنطن سيد حافظ الغويل الكبير
الباحثين في معهد الدراسات الدوليه في
جامعهن اهلا بكم ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك على
تربيه دعوتنا سيد حافظ
القنبله التي قتلت 270 شخصا علمتني رحله
باناميريكان 103 فوق اللوكربي بي اسكتلندا
عام
88,000 محتجزا لديها وسيمفل امام محكمه
اتحاديه في العاصمه واشنطن في جلسه استماع
الاولى اطرح عليك السؤال الاول من واشنط
سيد حافظ
دراسات الدوليه بجامعه جونس هوبكنس
مرحبا اخي الكريم يعني هو هذه القضيه تعقد
بطريقه منطقيه ومحايده هناك الوجه الليبيه
وهناك وجهه النظر الامريكيه الاتفاق الذي
وصلت الذي توصلت ليبيا مع الولايات
المتحده حول التعويضات كان الشق المدني من
هذه القضيه وبذلك انتهى ملف التعويضات في
الولايات المتحده الان لا تستطيع ان تطالب
بتعويضات جديده
اغلق بالاتفاقيه الدوليه المعترف بها من
الدوله الشرق الجنائي وهو البحث عن
المسؤولين الذين قاموا بهذا العمل لم لم
يتوقف لم يتوقف من من حتى الاتفاقيه لم
الولايات المتحده لم تقبل بان توقف
اجراءات متابعه من تعتقد انهم طلعوا في
هذه الجريمه ولذلك ما يحدث الان او همم
استلام الولايات المتحده لهذا المتهم شيء
طبيعي يعني ليس هناك اي مفاجاه في
المفاجاه الحقيقيه والتي اعتقد انها يعني
تداعياتها ستكون جديه وحقيقيه في الاسابيع
القادمه هي ان هذا التسليم همم حكومه
الدبيبه وزيرتها المنقوش همم يعني همم
خطفوا هذا الانسان اخرجوه اولا من السجن
بحجه انه مريض ثم سلموه بدون اي اجراءات
قانونيه
لهذا الامر جزءا خلال حلقتنا ولكن
يستسمعها كنا نطرح السؤال على ضيفي في
الجانب المقابل سيد ضوي المنصوري المحامي
وهمم رئيس لجنه القضيه المحكمه الدستوريه
في فئه صيغه الدستور اذا المنصوري بعد
اسابيع من الاخذ والرد في الداخل همم ليبي
وتاكيد اطراف عده معارضتها لاعاده فتح هذه
قضيه وزاره العدل الامريكيه تقول ان ابو
عجيله محمد مسعود بات في عهده السلطات
الامريكيه التي كانت واجهت له قبل عامين
اتهامات على خلفيه تفجير اللوكربي تعليقك
انت على هذا الامر دكتور ضوي منصور
همم انا اعتقد ان اعاده فتح الملف في هذه
الظروف في ظل هشاشه الدوله وفي ظل
التغييرات التي تطرا على ليبيا هو جهاز
انت هذه سياسيه همم لان همم السيد
مسعود ابو عجيل لم يكن خافي انه على
الولايات المتحده اثناء التحقيقات التي
جرت في قضيه ولم يوجه له همم اتهام
والقضيه برمتها همم يعني بكل التحقيقات
التي جرت فيها بدا ان المالطه وانتهاء
بالواقع التي وقعت فوق الاوربي والتحقيقات
التي اجرت والمحاكمات همم كانت شامله لكل
من له علاقه همم بهذه الواقعه ولم يكن
السيد مسعود ابو حسين همم
من ضمنهم همم
وبالتالي فان التسويات التي طرات على هذه
القضيه وانا هنا اختلف مع الاستاذ حافظ
الغويل بانهم تسويات متعلقه بالشق التعويض
اا وهذا اختلف فيه معه لان التعويض جاء
نتاجا نتاجا لفعل جنائي هذا الفعل جنائي
ارتبط اساسا بالتعويض وبالتالي فانه لا
يمكن فصل همم مساله المحاكمات التي جرت في
في في همم ايرلندا همم عن همم عن عن
تعويضات بموجب الاتفاقيه التي وقعت بين
ليبيا همم وامريكا في اربعه ثمانيه همم
2008 ومن تم فان اعاده فتح هذه القضيه هو
همم حقيقه همم
اا كان سيئا على الليبين
ويعبروا بشكل واضح وجليه ااه عن انتهاز
الولايات المتحده لهشاشه الدوله ول- همم
يعني همم
السلطات فيها غير قادر عند حمايه اقليمها
يدل على ذلك ان لم نسمع اي بيان يدل على
ان السلطات الليبيه همم قد سلمت همم مسعود
ابو عجيل المرمي الى امريكا مما يدل بان
هناك مسائل لا زالت خافيه همم ستظهر
الايام في القادمها
على هذه الامور الخافيه ايضا خلال لحظات
واعود اليك ضيفي سيد حافظ كبير الباحثين
في مع دراسات الدوليه في جماعه هوبكنس همم
ضيف يقول التعويض جاء نتاج بحث جنائي
وليكن الفصل بين المصرات اطرح لك سؤال هل
تؤيد انت اعاده فتح هذه القضيه اول خسرا
واترفع عديده ليبيا رسميه وغير رسميه ترف
ترفض ذلك تعتبر الملف مغلقا بالكامل
سياسيا وقانونيا وجنائيا وكل شيء بموجب نص
الاتفاقيه التي ابرمت بين الولايات
المتحده وليبيا في 2008 والتي تم تعزيزها
ايضا سيد حافظ لغويل بموجب الامر الرئاسي
الموقع من قبل الرئيس الامريكي السابق
جورج بوش في السنه نفسها كيف ترد على ضيفي
الذي لا يتفق معك في هذه النقطه انا وسر
ان هذه هي النقطه الموجوده في اتفاق ليبيا
لم تقبل ولم تعترف بانها مسؤوله على هذه
العمليه ولكن حصل يعني بطريقه قانونيه بان
لي التسويه بان لي بتدفع هذه المبالغ
للعائلات لاسباب يعني خلق صندوق همم بهذه
الاموال وكانت مقابل ان الولايات المتحده
ترفع كل العقوبات على ليبيا وتفتح السفاره
الى اخر هذه الكلام ولكن باللام تعترف
بانها مسؤوله على هذا الموضوع واسر ان اي
انسان
يرجع الى ذلك الطريق وهذه الاتفاقيه سيجد
ان الولايات المتحده لا لم تتنازل عن حقها
في متابعه همم المسؤولين مباشره ولكنها
قبلت انها لا همم يعني همم تتهم الحكومه
الليبيه وانها متابعتها تكون للافراد همم
وهذا كانت هي تسويه التي حدثت لا هو لم
يفتح الملف من جديد لان الولايات المتحده
وهذه العائلات لا تستطيع الان ان تطلع
ترجع لليبيا وتقول انها تريد تعويضات اخرى
لكن اؤكد من جديد ان اا المشكله الاساسيه
همم هي داخل ليبي وهي ان عندك حكومه همم
يعني سلمت انسان
ضد الاعراف الدوليه وضد القانون الليبي
نفسه همم بطريقه غير اغنيه ولا اخلاقيه
طيب يعني
الليبين متابعته سناتي ويجب متابعه هذه
النقطه والتحقق منها خاصه همم فعلا سيد
حافظ ذويل وكما قال ايضا الدكتور ضوي
المنصوري ليس لدينا ايه معلومات وليست
هناك حتى روايه رسميه من الجانب همم
ان اي احد يتكلم حتى مع المحققين
الامريكيين بما فيهم جماعه الاسبياء سيقول
انه يعني هي ليست ذنبهم ان والله عندك
حكومه غير شرعيه همم تتلاعب بالقانون اللي
هو شخصيه ولكن هذا معروف يعني ليس مش
محتاجه منهم اي بيان طيب همم الولايات
المتحده همم
عود اليك ضعيف الدكتور منصور قبل ان نتحدث
عن حكومه تدريب عمليه التسليم هل عمليه
ذلك همم كما تم تصويرها وفق روايات متعدده
دكتور ضوي المنصوري الملف جنائيا لم يغلق
ويؤكد لك همم ضيفي يعني ووصل في الولايات
المتحده حتى خلال تحضير هذه الحلقه ثما
تستغربنا ده كثيرين من رفض ليبيا اعاده
فتح هذه القضيه والهدف كل الهدف واحقاق
العداله وضمان المحاسبه خاصه ان ليبيا
ادانت وتدين بشده الاعمال الارهابيه هذا
بالاضافه الى انه ثم معطل جديد دكتور هو
همم في هذه القضيه اعيد فتحها همم بعد ما
علم القضاء الامريكي بتوقيف همم سيد مسعود
بعد سقوط نظام القذافي وانه قدم اعترافا
مفترضا لاستخبارات النظام الليبي همم
الجديد عام 2012 كثيرون يقولون هذه
المعطيات همم ربما تدعم الاتجاه نحو همم
تفعيل هذا الملف على المستوى الجنائي ولا
نتحدث عن مستوى تعويضات همم لاسر الضحيه
همم تفضل دكتور
هو حتى لانه وجه الخلافه بيني وبين
الاستاذ حافظ الغويل وهو القادر على اخذ
المعلومات من مصدرها
فالاستاذ ابراهيم الغويري للاستاذنا
الكبير هو الذي كان محاميا في هذه القضيه
واعتقد انه ليس بخافيا عن حافظ ان
الاتفاقيه شامله نصا واضحا صريحا مؤداه هو
عدم مسؤوليه الدوله الليبيه او احد
رعاياها اي بمعنى ان هذا الشق المتعلق
بالتحقيقات التي وردت في قضيه همم
قد تم قبلها سواء في مواجهه الدوله
الليبيه او في مواجهه احد رعاياها ودعني
حقيقه همم اطوره هذا الامر بالقول بان حتى
التهمه اصلا وهو اتهام السيد مسعود بعجيله
بانه قام بتصنيع قنبله هذه القنبله التي
ادت الى هلاك ااه
عدد من همم يعني ركاب طائره لقربي هذه
دعونا الى التساؤل بان حتى جرائم القتل
باستخدام السكاكين تسال عنه الشركه التي
صنعت هذه السكاكين ولا يسالوا عنها القاتل
ومن ثم حتى السيارات التي ترتكب حوادث
الطريق تصلوا عنها الشركه التي تحملها
لا في توسع في توسع لان هذا هذه القنبله
السيد همم سعود ابو عجيله لم يشارك مطلقا
في اي فعل جنائي من شانه ارتكاب ال- ال-
اعترافات السيد ضوء المنصوري في 2012 ثم
علمت بها الولايات المتحده لعلك ربما
بامكان ان تفيدني في هذا السياق اعترافات
مفترضه اولا دعني اقول لك بانني من
متابعين لقضيه لقربي منذ بدايه التحقيقات
فيها ولو وجود بالمطلق لاي اعترافات لهذا
السيد مسعود ابو عجيله في تلك الواقعه اذا
استجدت وقائع جديده بعد قفل الملف فداك
شان الاخر اما اثناء التحقيق في القضيه
حتى اجراء المحاكمه وتوقيع الاتفاقيه في
اربعه ثمانيه وصدور الامر الرئاسي من رئيس
جورج في 31/8/2008 فلو وجود بالمطلق لهذا
الاسم ولهذه الوقايه التي تتجدد جديده وهي
لا تحمل شيئا حتى اذا عرضت على المحكمه
اسكتلنديا فسيكون مصيرتها مصيرها عدم
مسؤوليه السيد مسعود ابو عجيله عن اي فعل
جنائي مرتبط بقضيه واقعه لوكربي وان زوج
بيه في هذه الفتره وفي هذه الظروف همم
يعني حقيقه وفي ظل ضعف الدوله الليبيه
المقصود منه هو هو ابتزاز في الليبي
واعاده حلب البقر اللي من جديد بعد همم
واعلافا طيب طيب
ما انت فعلا ابتزاز لغايه ماليه ما وهذه
خشيه صراحه لدى الليبيين بالاضافه الى انه
همم حتى تعود اليه السيد حافظ لغويل مع اي
داله ليبيا ومسؤوليها للارهاب لمحاكمه اي
مواطن ليبيا خارج بلاده ثم تخش من تكون
كما ذهبت الى ذلك منذ لحظات دون ان تكون
لدينا ادله مباشره على الاقل لديك همم فما
تخشن ان تكون عمليه تسليما مسعود قد جرت
خارج القطر القانونيه دون اشراف القضاء
الليبي لبعض يسال هل همم عمليه التسليم
همم تمت ضمن صفقه سياسيه ما خاصه اذا ما
ربطنا ذلك في تصريحات السفير الامريكي
ريتشارد نار لاند لصحيفه جنوب افريقيا همم
مؤخرا قال في تصريحاته عنبه نحن نعتبره
رئيسا مؤقتا للحكومه ليبيا ليست بحاجه الى
فريق اخر من الوراء قال مؤقتين هل مؤقتين
هل تم تفاعلا صفقه سياسيه ما من وراء ذلك
ما يقول منتقد بيبا نفسه
وطبعا هناك صفقه ولكن انا اعتقد ان
الخاسرين في هذه الصفقه هي هم دبيبه
وحكومته لان الولايات المتحده لا لا
تستطيع اطلاقا ان تحميهم من اي شيء او
خصوصا لا تستطيع ان تحميهم من مساء الى
قانونيه فضائيه داخل همم دولتهم يعني هذا
شيء لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده ولا ولا
اي رئيس للولايات المتحده يستطيع ان
يعطيهم ذلك كلمه النورلين خلاص يعني
سيتقاعد خلال شهرين همم وليس قيمه حقيقيه
لكلامه يعني هو يقول في شيء موجود على
الارض يعني هو مش الامر مش محتاج لنور لان
هو يقول ان والله دبي هو المسؤول الموجود
الان مؤقتا قيل هذا الكلام من سنه ليس
يعني في الاخير همم انا يعني استهزئ بان
الدبيبه او المنقوشه اعتقد ان ال ان بهذه
الطريقه يستطيع كسب الولايات المتحده
سياسيا الى ج ما هذا لن يحدث
وخصوصا لو هناك حراج داخل ليبيا لمحاكمتهم
لانهم تعدوا على القانون الليبي وسلموا
انسان مواطن ليبي بطريقه غير قانونيه وفي
همم في الليل يعني هو ما حدث سيد حكيم ان
هذا الرجل كان في السجن وهو يناهز
الثمانين سنه ومريض مرض عضال وانهم همم
دبيبه بعد يعني همم افرجوا عليه ووضعوه في
بيته تحت همم الاقامه الجبريه بحجه انه
مريض ثم بعثه ميليشيا تتبع دبي ومعروفه
وحتى تقول في ذلك الكلام تتبع وزاره
الدفاع الذي رقصها واخذوه في نص الليل ثم
اختفى الرجل يظهر في في واشنطن يعني هذه
مسؤوليه مباشر على دبي والمنقوش في نفسها
لان هي التي فتحت هذا الملف من كذا شهر
وتكلمت على تعاونها مع الولايات المتحده
في هذا الملف موضوع الادله فضه اعتقد انه
هو كل التطور بعد القضيه بعد محاكمات
النادر ل همم ولكن انا مقتنع قناعه شخصيه
ان هذا الرجل عندما ي- اا
يحاكم في واشنطن انا اعتقد بكل يعني
الواحد طبعا ما فيش اي تاكيد في العالم
ولكني
لدرجه كبيره اعرف انه س س س لن لن يداني
يعني طيب وانه سيخرج وراء طيب همم
ثمه مطالبه ايضا خشيه من المطالبه
بتعويضات ماليه جديده لم يحدث
همم
لكن احنا نرى احنا نتعامل مع رئيس وزراء
وحكومه مستعد ان تفعل اي شيء في سبيل
البقاء في السلطه يعني لو دبين يبقى
مستعده يدفع هذا امر اخر قانونيه همم لا
يحدث طيب التعويضات الماليه عطلت مع ضيف
السيد حافظ لان فقدنا الاتصال مع ضيف
الضوء المنصوري همم ااا من طرابلس المحامي
على كل اللي هو تحدث يقول ان كان تعتقد
حكومه دبيبه ودبيبه نفسه على الولايات س
سيكسب الولايات الى جانبه بهذا الامر في
هذا لن يحدث وتحدث عن تفاصيل همم توقيف
همم ابو عجيل مسعود في منتصف الليل الى
غير ذلك ولكن المهم ان ربما استمعت اليه
ان يقول لك ان هذه التعويضات الماليه لن
تحدث وهنا همم كما سالته عن هذه احتماليه
تكون هناك صفقه اسالك ايضا همم بناء على
الانتقادات المواجهه لحكومه دبي الان ولد
دبيبه نفسه هل تحاول هذه الحكومه فعلا كما
يعيب عليها البعض عبر هذا التسليم اطاله
ربما امت بقائها في السلطه عبر مقايضه
سياسيه او عبر تقديم اي تنازلات هل تتفق
مع ضيفي في هذا الامر اخدم معك دكتور
منصور
انا اعتقد
ان هذا الرجل قد ذهب ضحيه السياسيه
ورغبه العديد من الاطراف في البقاء في
السلطه وبالتالي مغازله الجانب الامريكي
الذي يملك يعني القسط الاكبر من التقرير
في بقاء هذه الاجسام في مكانها من عدمه
اما من الناحيه القانونيه
اعتقدوا جازما بان المساله لا تخرجوا عن
فقاعات هوائيه المقصود منها هو اثاره
الزوبعه من جديد
[موسيقى]
اا يعني اظهار ان الولايات المتحده
حريصه على تحقيق العداله ولو كانت
الولايات المتحده حريصه تحقيق العداله
التي كانت قد سلكت الطريق الصحيح لان
التسليم المواطنين الليبيين الى الى الى
الى الى دوله اخرى هو امر متعلق بالمسائل
المتعلقه بالسياده وبالتالي كان يجب ان
يكون علنا حتى يعرف الليبيين بان التسليم
باحد مواطنهم قد تم وفقا للقانون ووفق
الاجراءات الدبلوماسيه بين همم
وافقت كافه السلطات المختصره يقول لك هذه
المسؤوليه الحكومه الليبيه
بالتاكيد ولكنني دعني يعني اقول اذكر
السيد حافظ الغويل بان ال ال الذي يساهم
في في في في في مع المجرم في ارتكاب
جريماته هو شريك له واعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده يجب ان تربع بنفسها عن هذه
التفاهات وانت وهو هي اختراق القانون
والعبث بحقوق الانسان وانتهاك سياده
الدوله ضعيفه ليست مدينه
عن ذلك
تم تسليمه ربما باتفاقيه ماء داخل قطر
القانونيه لا هذا لا لم يحدث ذلك
غير غير قانونيه
وانا مستعد لذلك
كل وقت وانا اعيده في هذا الموضوع كل شكرا
انا اشكركم جزيلا الشكر همم في انتظار ان
تتضح اذكر الصوره بشكل رسمي خلال ساعات
الايام القليله المقبله كلها شك جزيل لكما
منا طرب لسيد ضوء المنصوري دكتور ذوي
المنصوري محامي ورئيس لجنه السلطه
القضائيه المحكمه الدستوريه في هذه سياقه
الدستور شكرا جزيلا لك على تلبيه هذه
الدعوه وكل الشكر جزيل لك ايضا على تربيه
دعوتنا من واشنطن سيد حافظ الكبير
والباحثين في معهد الدراسات الدوليه في
جامعه جونس هوبكنز واشنط شكرا جزيلا لكم
ان كنتم معنا في فقره في وجهان